public 1 la parole est à madame nathalie
kosciusko morizet merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
je veux appeler votre attention sur la
situation financière de la future
métropole du grand paris elle verra le
jour le 1er janvier prochain
mais on se demande bien comment elle
pourra exercer ses missions tant ces
moyens sont inadaptés le budget de la
ville de paris mes chers collègues ses 9
milliards d'euros le budget de la région
ces cinq milliards et la future
métropole du grand paris quant à elle
aurait un budget pour commencer de 70
millions seulement
mais c'est pas tout dans la loi de
finances le gouvernement prévoit
d'augmenter le fonds de péréquation des
ressources intercommunal de 220 millions
d'euros
alors personne ne conteste la
péréquation dont le principe d'ailleurs
a été établi par la droite
mais après la baisse massive des
dotations et l'année même de la création
des métropoles de paris et de marseille
cette nouvelle hausse est inadaptée si
on suit votre chemin la métropole sera
déficitaire
dès sa naissance à cela s'ajoute le
poids de l'incertitude liée aux
nouvelles conditions d'attribution des
dotations le ministère monsieur premier
ministre se dit incapable de fournir des
simulations financières
du coup ne connaît pas le montant total
de la ponction sur la métropole il
pourrait atteindre 380 millions d'euros
on ne sait pas non plus qui la
supportera par exemple il ya trente et
une communes essentiellement en seine
saint denis qui était bénéficiaire de la
péréquation en 2015 et qui ne savent pas
si elles le resteront en 2016
monsieur le premier ministre les élus de
la métropole toutes tendances politiques
confondues vous demande un moratoire le
temps de lancer le grand paris il faut
stabiliser le montant du fonds
péréquation pour 2016 il faut geler sa
répartition dans le périmètre de la
métropole monsieur premier ministre y
êtes vous prêts merci madame kosciusko
morizet la parole à monsieur secrétaire
d'état chargé du budget merci monsieur
le président
mesdames messieurs les députés madame la
ministre nathalie que ce que morizet
votre question est légitime et je vais y
répondre précisément le budget est
nécessairement le reflet des compétences
92% des élus concernés toutes tendances
politiques confondues ont signé une
motion en octobre 2014 pour demander une
montée en puissance très progressive des
compétences de la métropole du grand
paris le chiffre que vous donnez et donc
une estimation qui est suffisant pour
les compétences de planification de la
première phase
bien évidemment les règles du pic seront
adaptés à l'architecturé particulière de
la métropole en prenant compte les
capacités contributives de chacun
il n'y aura donc pas de déficit pour
aucun échelon et la métropole du grand
paris pourra boucler son budget nous
réunirons la semaine prochaine les élus
de droite comme de gauche qui ont
participé à la rédaction des ordonnances
financière et fiscale pour leur
présenter l'application de la réforme de
la dgf et du spic l'adaptation à leur
territoire il est logique qu'ils y
soient associés
madame la ministre vous avez fait durant
la législature précédente
deux grandes réformes de la fiscalité
locale en catastrophe
la taxe professionnelle on en parle on
en paye encore aujourd'hui les
conséquences
mais je vous l'accordé vous l'avais dit
la création du spic qui est un outil de
péréquation entre les collectivités que
nous avons voté c'était une bonne
réforme
elle prévoyait une montée en puissance à
2% des recettes fiscales du bloc
communal nous n'irons pas jusqu'à cette
somme nous répondrons partiellement à
votre attente mais neuf pic progressera
de 220 millions d'euros
parce que c'est un outil apprécié de
péréquation et de solidarité entre les
collectivités territoriales merci
monsieur le ministre pour le groupe
socialiste républicain